foreign
[Music]
well today we have one of the more
popular guests to have come on what a
lead already where he told his
incredible story where he went from
picking a spirit always thought the idea
of a podcast would be pretty cool this
is the most excited I've been to ever
guest on today he is an incredible
player and somehow even a bitter ladder
it is the great Conrad Smith Kendra Cox
it's welcome Richie Moana welcome
brother what an intro holy seven
episodes was the goal and I think I'm up
to now about 160 or something and just
just loving it I was thinking maybe a
comeback was coming
the success has sort of surprised me a
little bit and it's just been awesome to
I guess get messages from people after
episodes and saying how much they've
taken out of that or how awesome it was
to hear what that guy was really like
the boots are all hung up now they're
getting itchy feet the season started
absolutely not mate you could probably
do with the um
holy
in my Rugby career I think it was 12
years in the end starting here in Tasman
there was moves every sort of six months
started off with Italy then up to
taranaki and the Hurricanes headed over
to London Irish Red Sparks in Japan and
then hurricanes to finish
the back end of my career once I hit
sort of 28 29 I was really struggling on
my left hip in particular
struggle to put my left sock on and left
Bhutan before a game
it became a real mental battle for me to
prepare myself for trainings and get
through the week and
covert actually hit and I wasn't really
paying for the canes at the time and I
went up to the coach's room and said how
about this is a good opportunity to get
my hip surgery and in the back of my
mind I knew that I was
unlikely to return to the game
the coaching transition happened really
quickly
I just had my hip surgery I think I was
still on crutches I heard the news that
Carlos said left the Hurricanes so
I had a call from Jason Holland asking
if I would fill his role for the
remainder of the season
I was literally one day down on the
players Locker to the following day up
into the coach's box
[Music]
I asked Tasman if I could sign with
Tasman as a player I signed with them
for one dollar and that was just purely
to learn as much as I could as a coach
I was purely there pretty much to learn
off the likes of Andrew Goodman Clark
doomeday Shane Christie great news team
great news one of the media fraternity
is now going coaching with the Crusaders
James Marshall welcome to Super Rugby
mate yeah the Crusaders opportunity came
out of nowhere like I Was preparing for
this Tasman season I did promise my wife
there I wasn't going to chase the
coaching dream because we'd moved the
family so much
but when you get their phone call from
Razer you know the most successful team
in Super Rugby history
pretty hard offer to turn down
oh thanks again for coming on the water
Lab podcast mate always and yeah I don't
know the full plan of what's next for
what a lad because obviously the
Crusader's job is going to be pretty
intense
it's something that I really want to
keep doing potentially in the off season
might be a good chance for me to keep it
going and making sure I can give players
a platform to share their stories or
share what they want absolute honor
having Legends Like You on the podcast
so I really appreciate you giving up
your time you're a lad